en plus des coups de feu et des attaques
perpétrées à l aveugle
la menace d'une guerre chimique plane au
dessus de la ville poussant les
habitants les innocentes victimes de
cette guerre civile sanglante à se
demander qui est il arrivé au monde que
nous avons connue c'était franck votre
ville en direct de l'équateur se trouve
qu'on est tellement mieux ici à new york
en equateur on a du vin de quoi manger
on se fait pas tirer dessus tu es un
petit journaliste qui bosse dans une
radio locale croyez qu aujourd'hui tu
serait connu dans mon district je suis
ingénieur du son chéri vous faites une
bonne équipe
faut que tu t'en face pousse et berbères
de ça deux courbes désolé c'est parce
que tu as dit père moi je dis une paire
de seins mais je dis pas une paire de
couilles tu seulement les couilles on
devait aller en équateur et on se
retrouve dans un appart à new york juste
en face de la station de radio et nous
retrouvons en direct notre envoyé
spécial à quito en bonne le sable du
désert a plongé la ville dans une trêve
forcée
le ciel a changé de couleur le soleil a
quasiment disparu
je crois qu'on a besoin de plus d'un
coup je suis presque sûr que le sable
n'est pas un gros problème en equateur
ce que je sais la premi source et que
les deux envoyés spéciaux sont portées
disparues ils sont en grand danger
tout le monde nous recherche ce qui veut
dire qu'on doit aller en équateur pour
de vrai et pourquoi on doit aller en est
coûteuse et ça on va en flandre
c'est des gilet pare balles oui c est
pourquoi ils sont aussi t'as pas des
slips par balles sinon ça sert à rien
allez on y va on n'y va pas on y va je
te dis on n'y va pas
je voudrais faire appel à la générosité
du public américain si chacun d'entre
vous donnait juste un dollar pour nos
héros est ce que tout fait je vais lui
envoyer au dollar pourquoi faire pour
sauver mais excellente idée